each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available for the next session uh to
start start the next session um Sabre
kais is here from Purdue and he's going
to talk about challenges of electronic
structure calculations on quantum
computers okay thank you Justa for the
invitation
so yeah let me start by thanking my
students
who did the hard work and as you can see
we are involved in two main
projects one on Final siiz scaling and
Quantum
criticality and Quantum Computing and
Quantum information and of course this
is the topic for discussion
today
so I'm going to discuss Quantum
algorithms for
chemistry and I will start with the
shinger equation I'm not going to talk
about optimization but we are
interesting also in global
optimization and I will end with
discussing linear system of C equation
and how we can solve problem in
chemistry related to ax equal
B and I thought maybe at this point I
will mention couple problems
which might be related to our discussion
maybe for
tomorrow about how to take advantage of
superposition interference and
entanglement to understand fundamental
problem in
chemistry and for that we have couple of
problems one understand the coherence
and entanglement in
photosynthesis the second problem has to
do with the mechanism with which bear
determined magnetic
North and how
entanglement can teach us about the
outcome of a given chemical
reaction so for the first one we start
looking at the inment and coherence in
the EO
complex and now we are move moving to
lh2 which is a largest system 18 site
and we're doing this work with the alen
and Peter trying to understand the role
of ing M and coherence in
photosynthesis the other problem has to
do with
entanglement for
traing a polar molecular system in
Optical lce and here the idea is to come
up with a way to do the quantum Gates
needed for such a
system because it's extremely hard to
individually manipulate each Cubit on
this side because of the splitting is so
small and it's really hard to run the
quantum Gates so we are involved in this
project to see what we have to do in
order to design Quantum gates for such a
system and for that we collaborating
with Dudley herbach and britz love from
Berlin
Institute
uh for
this and the other problem is the as you
can see I have an undergraduate from Gan
college is about two hours north of
Purdue
and as you can see he's very happy to
work on this
problem and the basic idea is that in
the back of the eye of the bird there's
this complex protein system and for us
for just for Simplicity we can think
about you have donor acceptor we have a
blue Photon excite the electron to this
singlet State the electron transfer to
the acceptor and since both electrons
they have different nuclear environments
so they have different magnetic field
affecting the two spins so they start
oscillating singlet and triplet and the
oscillation singlet triplet which
depends on the environment leads to two
different chemical reaction and somehow
the link between the chemical reaction
and the how the bear decide about the
Earth magnetic field is still unclear
and this is an open problem and couple
groups are working in this direction try
to understand how the bird takes the
information from a chemical reaction and
know the dire ction El magnetic
field and the last problem I would like
to mention is related to entanglement in
chemical
reactions and we try to understand the
experimental
results of this German group they
publish this back in science 2007 and
the idea is to do the smallest two split
two split experiment you direct the H2
in
space and with high energy Photon you
ionize one electron
and the by correlation the other
electrons follow this one and you look
at the angular distribution of the fast
electron and it's not clear at this
point how do you extract information
about entanglement from such an
experiment so now I would like to
discuss the our involvement in
developing Quantum algorithm to solve
the Shing
equation
I mean for us in this field we are lucky
we know the hamiltonian so we don't have
to make an effort to devise the new
hamiltonian all the forces are known as
colic forces and all we have to do is
just solve this linear second order
linear differential equation with colic
forces so if you look at the the
development of methods for solving the
Shing equation
and if you look back on the heart method
this was developed back in
1932 so we talk about almost 80 years of
research to solve such an
equation and of course over the years
people developed many different methods
so I
can maybe talk about conventional and
nonconventional methods to solve the
shinger equation and I would like to
mention just that unconventional because
I was involved in uh the development so
I will just mention the algebraic method
which the basic idea is use Le groups
and Le algebra to solve this
equation and this is where my PhD and
then I did po do with dimensional
scaling and I get my tenure at Purdue
developing the final scaling so people
ask what is the difference between
conventional and unconventional
methods I will say unconventional method
when you go back look at your papers you
see you only the only one citing your
work
so with the just like I would like to
mention the outcome of these different
methods so you can see where we standing
and the question I'm trying to raise are
we done developing classical methods to
solve the sh equation this is my point
can we still design better classical
algorithm to solve the equation probably
Garen we'll talk about it in his density
maximum majes but I mean there's a
question here are we done or we still
there is a hope that we can develop more
efficient classical methods to solve the
shinger equation so just like I would
like to mention
the the results for from RE from the
leag
groups and the idea is to write the
hamiltonian in the generators of a given
leag group and probably will I was a
graduate student took me one year to
figure out the only system can be solved
is the hydrogen atom and you need the
orthogonal S so4 group and then I tried
another year solving the helium atom
with no success because there was no way
to write the H in generator of Any Given
group so before giving up this problem
at the end I decided to look what kind
of the
interaction we can modify in order that
we can solve this problem keeping the
electron electr interaction of course
because this is the main point here
keeping the electro interaction and it
turns out that if I change the colic to
harmonic interaction only certain values
of K for this one only K 1/4 you can
solve this
analytically and it's really interesting
because everybody thought in this field
that there is no way to solve this
system analytically and it's not clear
yet why k equal 1/4 the system admit an
analytical solution but anyway you can
solve this exactly analytically and you
get the wave function the
density and this is the only system
where you keep the electon electon
interaction and you still solve the
system
analytically and again the if you look
at the correlation energy it's I still
remember the number it's 0.004 Atomic
units where the helium is 042 it's very
close to the helium atom if you're
looking at the
correlations this is the electron
interaction is colic but but attach yeah
the external feed instead of colic you
change it to
harmonic so anyway maybe there is still
hope for analytical solution in this
field
and for the rization group
techniques again the basic idea is to
start with rization group techniques
design the way wison did it in condensed
matter and also the same here very
quickly you'll realize that it's
impossible to do rization the way Wilson
did it directly from the partion
function by reducing the number of
degrees of freedom and it took us over a
year to solve it for helium and was
numerically impossible to follow for any
other system and we stopped here this
was 1998 but garet has a smarter idea
you go to density metrix rization group
instead of Wilson rization group any so
the conclusion with the Wilson rization
group it's almost impossible to do
electronic structure
calculations and now the dimensional
scaling the idea instead of solving the
problem in threedimensional space which
is hard and we know that it's scale
exponentially can we we do calculation
at different dimension by generalizing
the hamiltonian to the dimensional space
solve it at certain Dimension and then
go back say okay now I'll go back to
three dimensional space it turns out for
electronic structure it is extremely
simple to go to the large D limit d goes
to
Infinity all you have to do is
minimizing an effective
function and then you do vertion Theory
so the large D limit is good for
localization if you have a localized
electron this is an excellent
approximation
otherwise you have to do vertion Theory
and you get to the old Troubles of doing
bation
Theory so again just to summarize this
this method only good for localized
electron okay so now we're dealing with
exact calculation not approximation we
exact calculation and we already
discussed it that the calculation time
of the energy of atoms and molecules
scale
exponentially with the size of the
system and where this comes from if you
are doing full C I calculations and you
have n orbitals and M electrons the way
to distribute the M electrons in N
orbitals goes like exponentially here
with number of
electrons and you can see the number of
configurations for a given number of
electrons and orbitals grow
exponentially and I always like to give
this simple molecular system the
methanol with 18 electrons and 50 basis
functions so are not not talking about
100 is just like 18 electrons the number
of configurations needed to do full CI
is 10
2017 and maybe you can correct me as far
as I know I haven't seen any classical
calculation with 10 to the 17
configurations so the maximum I
encountered was 10 to the 9 this was
back in 99 I think the people can go to
10 to the 10 turn to the
11 is this is
correct so even EOL with we are not
talking about 100 electrons only
18 you cannot do the calculations on a
full
CI classical
computer okay so how do you approach
this problem we already discussed the
how to find the energy but for us in
chemistry I mean we have the hamiltonian
we have to represent the
hamiltonian we have to initialize the
wave function quantum computer and we
have the phase estimation algorithm we
already discussed it how to use the
phase estimation algorithm to solve this
problem so I not go back to the pH
estimation we already discussed
it and maybe I mention here the work ofn
group where you write the hon in a
second quantized form and then you try
to design the circuit for each term and
maybe I'll just give you the reference
wasle physics
and the idea here is to go from thionic
representation of the of the operator to
the SP to the B spin
matrices and of course in this field was
the first paper in science for H2 Alan
and Peter and then the experiment was
done I'm
sorry this was published in nature so we
know how to represent the material for
H2 we know how to do the simulation we
know how to do the the experiment was
done in principle and the question is
what
next so what is the challenge in this
field so I have a student in my group
from computer science and every time he
was giving a group meeting he will say
well I will apply the Black Box apply
the black box and so on so I told him in
chemistry you would like to open this
box and see what's inside and this is
what the challenge for us I mean how do
we write you for a given Mo
hamiltonian so so for that we said okay
for practical reason let us for a given
U Can we come up with
the use the optim optimization method
just regular optimization method to come
up with the best sequence for a given
metrix U oh this is in the right
direction
yeah so again this you will see in a
minute this is not an efficient way
because I mean the maximum number of
Gates goes four to the nend and this is
optimization for practical
reasons
and of course if you look at the
literature there are two different kind
of methods you have deterministic
methods and stochastic method to mean
optimization that we are used and people
use before us genetic algorithms and
many other algorithms but my student was
able to design a new
algorithm which was better for such an
optimization and the algorithm is the
the group leader optimization
algorithm and the idea you defy the
space into group
and each group you choose a leader which
is the best one in a group and then the
you will see a minute I will show you
the flowchart for this algorithm very
similar to the genetic
algorithm so the steps in the algorithm
is you Generate random population for
each group you calculate the fitness and
I will mention in a minute how do you
calculate the fitness for for such a
metrix and you determine the leaders for
each each
group and then very similar to genetic
algorithm you try to do mutation and
crossover between the
different
populations so what is the fitness here
so we're looking at the trace of the
metrix that you would like to decompose
into sequence of gates times the Target
and of course if UA equals the target
this is one trace of one n
so if will be one and then Epson will be
zero so this is the fitness for our
optimization and at each step we have to
calculate this function and choose the
population the leader for each
population and then do the mutation and
crossover so here are the results
for the hamiltonian hamiltoni of H2 and
for
water so here has the Fidel error as a
number of here we have the number of
iterations and you can see the
conversions in the Fidelity error and
also since you have you optimize the
number of gates for two Cubit and one
cubit you have to also give a cost
function higher for the two Cubit gate
than comparing with a single uh Cubit
gate so we are minimizing the
space with the look at the Fidelity and
the error in the cost of of the of the
quantum
Gates so here is the Quantum circuit for
the
H2 and for this one he succeeded to do
18 Quantum Gates and I think if I'm not
wrong with the first paper with the four
with the four Cubit you need 256 I think
was 256 Quantum gats so for practical
reason for this simple system
hamiltonian we able to reduce the
quantum G from
250 into 18 Quantum
Gates and the second one the same with
the five cubits for this is the Quantum
circuit from the optimization
algorithm for
water and again we discussing this with
experimental group to see if they can do
the
experiment for such a quantum
circuit I mean the difficulty you see in
the control here but we're trying to
simplify
this Quantum circuit so they can do the
experiment for the
H2O yes so Ste glass really like NMR
work doing this kind of stuff um seems
like the problem is you have to be
basically have to be able to solve you
to do the
minimization so what what's your
perspective on kind of like
being able to do blocks like like
obviously if you got to a big a larger
thing fit so no of course I mean if yeah
if it's I mean it's a this what I'm
saying before it's an efficient for
smaller u i mean if we have larger
metrices this is not the way to go so
this is like a yeah this is very
important point because if we have
larger met then it's really very hard to
come up with the sequence for
needed water why was there five Cub for
this one yeah yeah this is because the
the metrix for water was larger than we
need like larger basic set because it
depends how many Bas function you use go
from H2 to water so you need larger
basis function to represent the water
the is just the spin orbitals it isn't
five spin orbitals why isn't it much
larger I don't understand why it's only
five yeah for for H2 we use two basis
functions and then you have two it's
like you have two to yeah but for this
one we add for water we use the
multi-reference wave function as a
initial guess for the wave function so
we have more basis functions to
represent the huran than water because
in the water we are interesting in the
excited States not only the ground
state now so the idea can we come up
with the this is the question here can
we come up with the universal programing
Quantum circuit I will give you the
hamiltonian here is the molecular system
can you give me the quantum circuit
design for a given hamiltonian so we
work on this one and
the
we have an idea but it's not really
efficient because the scaling of this
one was still four to the n and the idea
is to add and SE a cubit to control the
I will show in a minute this is the idea
so we start with the with this Matrix so
this is the initial input and this is
output and the question is can we
enlarge this by Ancilla cubits in a way
that we can still read the output of
this one in the larger
space so what is the main B point would
like to come up with a way that we all
changing in the quantum circuit is just
the angles of the rotation so you give
me H2 and I can read directly what are
the angles in the rotation related to H2
give me water lithium hydride all I have
to do we have a fixed design and only
the rotation angle of the the the the
gates are changing so this is our
objective here and our goal and of
course I mean the way we design it with
uh with doubling the
Cubit is not efficient but at least when
this way we have a a fixed Quantum
circuit design for given hamiltonian and
all we changing is this the rotation
angles so this is was
the the basic idea
here and you need these to uniformly
control the V
here so we have three steps the
formation and the the
combination let me just go to the
directly to the water
here
so the final qu circuit design all we
have to do is just here the changing the
rotation angle and the rotational
G so let me just go to the water so this
is was the Honan we used for water but
you can see the spacity the these are
only the elements far away from the
diagonal and there is a
way to bring those one to closer to the
diagonal and change the bandwidth of The
Matrix so it will be easy to control and
add the number of uh Cubit to the design
of this H2 H for the
water so this is was now when we design
it this way we get for the hydrogen
molecular is the larger circuit we have
32 Gates and N of them are rotation and
the rest are X so all we have to do in
this one is just changing the rotation
angle and here we have the table
for relating The Matrix elements with
the
rotational angles in this
Gates so this is work for this small
system and the idea is really how to
come up with a fixed Quantum design for
us in quantum chemistry this is very
important because once we have this
design I can go from any mo hamiltonian
to another mole Honan just by changing
the rotation
angles and of course if you look at the
history of how quantum chemistry the the
development of the
computation once people discover how to
do the integral in a gaussian fashion
and you have the starting the gaussian
say company back in 1973 so you have a
systematic way for ungiven hamiltonian
you calculate the Matrix elements and
then you put it in the program and you
run it and would like to come up with
something like the same here in quantum
chemistry a fixed design I give you the
hamiltonian you change the Angles and do
the
simulations so here I would like to
mention also trying
to
uh work with the algorithm for solving
linear equation and this is the
algorithm was
designed by Sith Lloyd and Har this back
in
2009 and the basic idea for any given
Matrix a and a vector B find the vector
X such that you have ax equal B and you
can see the basic idea is to invert The
Matrix a to this side so you can get get
the vector X and you run into problems
that we discussed before about the the
the singularity of this Matrix and this
is also depends I mean here the
conditional number the conditional
number is the ratio between the highest
and the smallest I value of the Matrix
so if the Matrix is close to Singularity
it's like you will be hard to invert it
and you can see this is in the
scaling so the best classical algorithm
is case like order n Square Ro of K and
log one Epsilon and K is the the the the
condition number where the quantum still
you have exponential speed up log n but
you still have K Square here and this is
the problem in this algorithm that the
scaling go from square root of K to K
Square so if this Matrix is singular
then you have problem of inverting the
Matrix now what is the basic idea in
this algorithm that instead of working
with the Matrix a you go phe estimation
algorithm exponential e to the a this
will invert The Matrix and then you have
the I
values you have the vector
X so what is the input the input you
write your vector b as a Quantum State
here the summation here and the output
will be the vector
X and the basic idea in this algorithm
is to do the phase estimation algorithm
e to Theus a i a a is the Matrix that
you're trying to to invert and T So
essentially we're running the again the
phase estimation algorithm to get the
vector X for the ax equal B
system is
a yeah we assume information here we
discuss it if not Herm Mission you can
write it you can you enlarge it so you
have
it this is the the quantum circuit for
solving this linear system of equation
and as I mentioned
before the crucial step here which take
us back to the phase estimation
algorithm is how to
run U which is eus I a so we have again
an algorithm you need algorithm to
represent this
exponential and then once you know how
to represent this U you can run the
quantum circuit and get the the vector
X so for this
one we tried to collaborate with the
experimentally group with Professor D in
in NMR in China and we give them this
simple Matrix which is just 2x two and
you can see the Simplicity here the
output of this action and they were able
to do the simulation with four
qits using NMR and this is the molecular
system they used so they have four
cubits carbon 13 and the the three fine
atoms and they run the experiment with
four cubits and they
get the the results they run this
Experiment three times and you can see
with the Fidelity I think was
97% so they just this they finished this
experiment like two weeks ago and we
start we just discussing the results
with them and we're trying to summarize
our results the quantum circuit that we
did and their experiment with 4 Cubit to
solve x equal B so I mean this is again
a proof of principle that if you have a
linear system of equation as Alan and
Peter and other did with the with the H2
we can also if we have a quantum
computer we can solve ax equal b as they
did in this in 4 Cubit NMR
experiment how does it
scale go to the end yeah for the black
box that
you yeah again I mean the problem with
this with the metrix I mean this one
is because of the I mean again maybe
this is the the the other point I have
to mention with this algorithm a x equal
B it's efficiently to calculate a
function of the vector X which is the
average any average operator with not
individual component of the vector X
because then you have to read it in
whatever in times and until now it's not
clear what is the operator of interest
in Us in chemistry that the average of
that operator will be related to the
solution so we're trying to figure out
what is the average operator which will
be F chemistry and we are thinking about
scattering Theory where this equation
comes
in and this Vector will be related to
one of The Columns of the Matrix in
scattering so I think still there's a
hope that maybe this can be related to
scattering Theory but it's not clear
what is the operator that needed for
such a system how do you implement the
in general with General a I think that's
the big challenge yeah yeah I mean yeah
this goes back to the pH estimation yeah
yeah yeah
so I mean the last uh the last system
that I would like to mention is the
solving the Shing equation in ADBA cond
computer so what is the basic idea here
we
have we have an initial
hamiltonian and we changing a parameter
is from 0 to one if this is one you go
to the final hamiltonian if in zero you
start with the initial hamiltonian and
of of course what you need in this
system you need a initial
hamiltonian easy easy to implement
experimentally has a ground state that
simple to calculate and of course for
example just the sum of the the PO X
matrices and the idea is to come up with
the final hamiltonian again which can
experimentally implemented and the
solution of the final hamiltonian is the
one you are looking
for and as a two an example of the two
local aonian is the Z and z zonian and
this is was already implemented in the
d-wave
machine so the idea if we can bring our
hamiltonian into this kind of
form to
local at least we can implement it now
with the D machine but if not if it's
more complex the question if can we can
start with the more complex hamiltonian
and move to a Honan with larger number
you'll see in a minute for example in in
H2 we don't have a two local we have K
local and I will explain it in a minute
and the question how do you start in in
in atic one do Computing with the
hamiltonian which will lead to somewh
hamiltonian that you can relate it to
electronic structur
calculations so again is the this is the
spin Honan in the d-wave machine with
the ZZ
interaction and of course you can see
the import of this one because this one
is just looking at the minimum of this
quadratic function where J is the Matrix
here and this W is the vector and of
course you can if any problem can
be recast in this form of quadratic and
constraint B optimization you can run it
on this on this
machine and of course if you look back
in the ax equal B is the same you
minimizing this
quadratic function so also in principle
we can run a xal B on the D of
machine same princi how many bits of
accuracy do you need in the coupling
because that machine yeah of course yeah
I mean yeah this is does not scale well
with the size of the system with the
with the with the
coefficient just how much do the yeah
coefficients vary in magnitude that's
the question because they can PR up to
three bits yeah so kind of one 1 2 3 and
four and
not the number you need for your exactly
because we I me to we run this we run
this axal B on the machine and the
results were not better than any
classical algorith so we were not
getting good results from the D machine
but we are not done yet so I don't want
to really discuss at this point but the
the results from D web machine of this
optimization was less efficient than uh
uh the classical algorithm for solving
this equation and this is because of
your point of the
couling so we run this one I think up to
60 I mean I think we were from small
size 2x2 up to 16 it's not getting
better results than the classical
algorithm on the dwa
machine okay so now let's go back
to electronic structure
hamiltonians and use the vigner Jordan
transformation to go from fonic operator
to spin operators and see what kind of
interaction we end up with this
transformation so I'm giving the example
of
H2 so if we write this transformation
this is the H we are getting for H2 so
you have two
local you have ZZ here two local and
again this the h11 is the one electron
integrals and with the four indices the
two electron
integrals so you can see up to this
point we can still run this kind of
algorithm in atic on
Computing and using the D machine to get
the electonic structure but the higher
order terms with the four indices here
for the which related to The Exchange if
you look at the order this is eight
logal so in order
to to do electronic St calculations with
the arotic quantum Computing we need an
efficient way to go from local maybe in
this case we have eight local to two
local and this is what we're trying to
do to use perspiration
Theory to reduce this eight local
hamiltonian into two local and I know
Peter did I think you did the three to
two
yeah I'm two mhm
yeah so this is the question we are
facing now and I thought maybe we can
have it for discussion how do you do how
do you reduce the
the eight local
interaction in electronic structure and
you can see why the eight because we
have these four terms
here so if we come up with a method to
really reduce the eight to two we'll be
able to do run a electronic structure
calculation on AA to
machines so this is one case and another
case you said okay I I'm not starting
with two I can do for example three or
four and then the question how do you go
from eight to that number that will
allow you to go from initial hamiltonian
to the final
hamiltonian so I thought this may be the
question we can have it for discuss
yes the fact you have a four index term
there is a function of your basis so if
you choose basis functions which have
compact support which don't overlap you
have the the second term only you have
two indices this one
yeah so you mean this because I mean you
can see what we did here we just
transformed this foric operator into
proba spin matrices and these are the
Matrix element are you saying these are
can be reduced this is the question I
mean this is general has to do with Bas
fun even inic form you can reduce a for
index term to a two index term if the
basis functions have local support so
for example you work in real space the
Kum operator is a pair operator right
because because you're working a Delta
function basis it's got local support So
if you worked in the finite element
basis the culum operator becomes airse
operat if you if you work in fin element
you get to two yeah
well think about the overlap Matrix the
overlap so you need to take um P1 the
integral is PQ times RS and P Q have to
overlap yeah I have to think about it
because if there's way to reduce this
one to two then we can we can I mean we
can yeah I mean let me just finish and
we can discuss it yeah it's interesting
because this is our goal if we succeed
to do to break it down to two local I
mean in principle we can doic structure
but I mean
yeah this is a good point to discuss
because I I mean I didn't thought about
this one that you can reduce it to
two no excellent point no I mean this is
really our goal because if this is true
and I can do electon exu
now okay
good and still the D machine is is is
available with like they are moving to
500 Cubit so but but my current machine
you still need it to condensed to a ham
that
commutes say it again so I'm not so so
the terms you can use are all Computing
trips yeah which is slightly different
than the problem of can I go to a two
Cubit form of non-cued trips mhm oh okay
I see point to
we more generally from on a Computing
perspective we know that two local
hamiltonians are Q&A complete mhm so I
can
always simulate a four four local and
local hon two local terms well you can
always embed the graph yeah just the
overhead is going to kill you oh
sure the I'm missing sorry so I'm
missing one thing about the this overlap
so since the kumit repulsion is long
distance MH um so okay so the statement
I'm making pertains to the first Formula
where formul that's a sum of the four
terms for the Kum operator right that's
a function of using an underlying base
but the co operator you know is a
pairwise operator so why do you have
four indices it's because you're using
an underlying basis which has overlap
with where which doesn't have compact
support right right so I agree so if we
go to a Delta function basis Delta
function or just a finite element basis
right so that can be reduced to a pair
wise I'm just answering sub's original
question how do I reduce the the B of
those interactions you just introduce
final support to your faes but for
effect
for a fixed accuracy of representation
of the wave function you won't get the
same you'll have to have more of those
Bas fun well they might not be as
compact as a gin basis but I mean you
know people use different kinds of basis
functions in
chemistry okay as we mentioned this
before like but I would like here to
mention at the end I'm trying to connect
and this is really an open question what
we did uh
in fin scaling to the to the Glo to
theba Quantum Computing I mean suppose I
have a method which will tell me where
is the
gap does this is help us in the reducing
the evolution time because when you
close to the Gap you have to be very
slow so if somebody give me the Gap
where is the gap in the given
hamiltonian can this speed up the
calculations and for that I'm trying to
connect it with what we did before for
any given hamiltonian in quantum
mechanics a functional parameter
we devise a what we call the final
scaling which will give us that point
where the system Cross or avoid the
cross as a given with as a functional
parameter and let me just so the idea
was in qu mechanics you take a web
function and you expand in a basis set
and now I can look at the criticality
not in the thermodynamic limit I can
look at criticality in the in the hbert
space where the number of basis
functions infinite is go like a
thermodynamic limit but if the basis
function is finite I can use fin scaling
in hbert space to detect where is the
criticality or where the Gap is going to
be so we have done this one before for
any given hamiltonian with with the
parameter and this is maybe almost over
10 years ago and just to give you an
example how this works if I have a hilon
with a given parameter and expanded in a
finite basis
set I can do the ansers in final size
scaling instead of the thermodynamic
limit n will be a number of basis
functions and might be here for us
cubits
and then from this one this is the same
answer use in fin scaling in
thermodynamic uh calculations but we can
repeat it in the hbert space and there
is analogy between hbert space and the
thermodynamic limit and from there I can
for example here's the H with a
parameter we Define a finite B set and I
can see if I run it with
the with increasing Bas set I can get
the crossing point crossing point is the
critical point for the given hamiltonian
so if you give me your hamiltonian I can
tell you exactly where this Crossing is
going to
be so the question is if I know where
Crossing in the ADBA qu Computing does
this help to reduce the time because I
will be very
fast very fast in the evolution until I
get close to the critical point and then
I will slow
down and the question is how to turn
this one into an algorithm where we can
take advantage of this point and get
different scaling for because I mean
what killing you is the slow
Evolution so this I thought maybe will
be interesting to for
discussion and for I mean the algorithm
works because we also checked the the
the the inverse which is the data
collapse and we get Universal curve so
there is no doubt that this is analogy
Works between the thermodynamic and the
and the h
space again I would like to end with
this positive note if we have a qu
computer
will benefit Cony and I'd like to thank
my my group who is doing the hard
work thank you for your
attention I don't know if you said it
but why why can't the dway computer
Implement that something that's not s
SD what are people doing with the D I
mean probably videos experimentally I
mean they have Z they cannot do the why
can't they do anything well they they
actually they can so they can do for
example ZX or they can do XX um they
haven't um I think the reason they
haven't is just because they're very
interested in these combinatorial
optimization problems that they can sell
more easily a more striking restriction
they have is that they can only make
hamiltonians which are St clastic
meaning that all of the off diagonal
elements and have the same sign so that
all of the signs and those weights and
those paths that we were seeing before
have the same sign that means that the
has no sign yeah yeah that's right so
they can only simulate Hamilton which
has no
sign but then
they yeah they can but they can be
frustrated they can be frustrated so I
mean they formally they're doing some
quadratic binary optimization which is
formally Q
complete so formally you ought to be
able to di anything up on it if you have
ignoring
constant you had a big enough machine
that did this thing you can L put
any you have a complete problem you can
put any qu problem on it to poal factors
so now we're all fighting
about real details which are always
think not fighting
about but that will also be a big
problem for doing Quant chem on
it any on problems except yeah this
is there any other questions or
comments okay
let's okay so now we're going to hear
from Peter love from haford college and
he's going to talk about fironic Quantum
simulation so thanks for the is my mic
TR on can you hear me so thanks for the
invitation so I just wanted to say for
those of you who don't know hord college
if this is the largest curiosity driven
Enterprise we might be the smallest
curiosity driven Enterprise so we're a
liberal arts college about 15 minutes
outside
Philadelphia and this was work done with
Jake cely who's a who was a senior at
haford as part of his senior thesis and
um he's unfortunately gone
into uh climate science he'll be going
to Berkeley in the spring which is good
news for station Q because it means
you'll be able to stay in the same floor
of the
building you're quite close to the C
there right so okay so I just wanted to
start with some general comments sorry
there's a figure missing here um so
there's been a lot of interesting uh
developments in thinking about the
difference between bosons and Fons um so
bosons by which I mean photons let's
just stick to things that we can
literally see um so that's why you can
see me the photons in this room are
bouncing off me they're interacting with
the atoms that make me up and they're
bouncing back into your eye they're not
bouncing off each other so Photon
photons interactions are in ignorable
non-existent but the fascinatingly you
know the the there's this great uh km
theorem that says in spite of the fact
that photons don't interact with each
other one can still build a universal
linear Optical quantum computer by using
measurements and feed forward to um to
to create effective interactions between
the photons and do Gates um of course
one needs lots of technical things like
lots of good sources for single photons
on demand that we don't have right now
and good detectors that we're getting
there but nonetheless Universal Quantum
computation with linear Optics no
problem um more interestingly still you
know these bonic Lo local hamiltonian
problems so if you restrict if you know
that you have no sign problem so you
just um get rid of them this is work
done by zui uh who's just got a faculty
position position at um Stony Brook he
told me a funny story which is he
published paper saying you know bonic
hamiltonians are just as hard as fironic
hamiltonians and they said you know I
got some angry emails from the quantum
uh Monte Carlo Community I said really
who from he said well I got an email
from this guy Bernie Alder um so so this
was a somewhat surprising result but
nonetheless it's true and then more
recently Scott Ronson's work showing
that even sampling from the
distributions uh implied by uh simple
uh linear Optical circuits can be hard
so okay so that's yep I just want to ask
a question about your second bullet
point and maybe you or some computer
scientist in the audience can answer I
was reading in uh Scott Aronson's recent
posting on the archive he he says that
the KLM uh procedure allows Universal
Quantum computation uh if inhance by
post
selection so does anyone uh know exactly
what that means other words my
impression is that linear Optics is not
a universal uh model for Quantum
computation without some uh fancy
unrealistic computer science uh
adjectives such as post selection it's
not so it's just the the state that you
need to generate what's nice about it is
well it's post selected but it's
heralded it's heralded yeah I don't know
what that means so well so what it means
is okay so it's post selected but it
doesn't contain any data so you have to
you have some part of the photons that
has all the data and then you have some
state that you need to
generate which you have to post select
you have just for myself and maybe so
post selection is something that's not
physically realistic you have to repeat
something many times and then only use
the thin fraction of cases where what
you're post selecting for actually
occurs um that's right but you can make
it
realistic if it doesn't if if you're not
if it doesn't corrupt the data right so
the the most powerful no but you might
have to repeat some experiment
exponentially often before you find an
instance that you're poos to work you on
yeah so you you make you have to make
some tradeoff between space and time
right and what's nice about the km
scheme is that you can improve the
probability of getting the state you
want at a cost of space so you figure
out but polinomial space or exponential
space polinomial
space um so you figure out you know how
big of an algorithm you want to
run and then you have to put aside a
chunk of
resources to to do the post selection to
start but it's different than because
Scott sometimes talks about if you have
a quantum computer where you could do
Post selection on the quantum computer
which puts you into like a completely
different that's I that's what I thought
we were discussing but yeah so so in
this case you need post selection but
it's somehow it's weaker because it
doesn't do anything to the data it's
just for Preparation so so uh is uh
linear uh linear Optics is it uh bqp
complete or not yeah uh yeah
with so all this post selection that's
necessary can actually be in principle
implemented only
overhead that's right
yeah
okay can I ask a question third and
fourth points so from a simpleminded COR
money Carlo perspective can you tell me
what the trick here is just that this is
essentially a frustrated Hamilton and
that's why it's hard or yes that's right
that's so there's there's also a um a
nice paper by Sergey bravi on stochastic
hamiltonians in which he essentially
proves that
Quantum Monte Carlo without frustration
and without the sign problem is
efficient which perhaps you felt that
you knew but now there it's nice to have
some more rigorous argument okay so
let's see what trouble I can get in on
slide number two so um okay so let's
think about firion meaning electrons so
of course electrons have wav like
properties so we can take these very
nice electron micrographs um and of
course electron electron interactions
are strong it's worth saying out loud if
we're talking about chemistry and
fascinatingly there's a paper by um
Manny nil as soon as they did km the
obvious question was well what happens
if you do this construction for fion for
fermionic the equivalent of fermionic
linear Optics which I think um perhaps
is the answer to what Garnet was saying
earlier so if you only have the the
pairwise term in that hamiltonian that's
the linear Optical regime now fermionic
linear Optics is not Universal so you
cannot you cannot do the the equivalent
km scheme with fermion therion sampling
is easy because we can calculate
determinants well and but thermion local
hamiltonian is still qma
complete so it's nice to have these
little sketches of a few complexity
theoretic results that way one can talk
a little more
generally however this Talk's extremely
um specific I've really enjoyed today
because it's been a lot of depressing
negative ncy talk about things I'm very
interested in however I think the the
questions have been exactly right
you know when we um thought about this a
while ago you know the algorithms we
have now are concatenations of
constructions and those constructions
are there's no reason to believe and no
claim even that they're optimal in fact
you know if you really end up doing
serious chemistry on a quantum computer
a long time in the future there's no
reason to believe it would look anything
like anything that anyone said today
perhaps there are completely new ideas
hopefully we'll have some tomorrow so
here are the steps so the mapping Fons
to cubits we've already heard quite a
lot about anzat States uh and from Jared
about you know mapping these things onto
a real quantum computer State
preparation of those ANZ that's I um
phase estimation has already been
defined and then we that gives us a nice
digital read out of the energy so I want
to talk about the not the key steps so
the mapping of a fironic wave function
to cubits and then combined with trotz
so today this talk is about the mapping
it's about picking out just one step of
this concatenated construction and
trying to improve
it so I'm just going to talk about how
do you more efficiently map fermionic
states and thionic operations onto
cubits okay so I'll just briefly blow
through this because we've already heard
it today so okay this here's a set of or
orbitals spin orbitals for water um so
they're typically one electron energy
igon functions from some method um the
key point for but today is just okay
they're firion so each of these orbitals
can be occupied or unoccupied and so you
form many electron bases from
antisymmetrized product so this is the
idea of Slater
determinance so what do we think about
here well we have an occupation number
basis um so if we represent a state of a
chemical system in cubits we use the
occupation number basis so we assign a
cubit to an orbital a state zero of that
Cubit is that orbital is unoccupied a
state one of the Cubit is that orbital
is occupied um this has
been this idea has a history um actually
goes back to Palo zardi who originally
wrote this down thinking not about
chemistry but thinking about
entanglement in fonic
systems so this is the figure from the
2005 paper it just says if you do that
then your estimate for numbers of cubits
uh is more reassuring and encouraging
than your estimate for number of cubits
for say interesting factoring problems
there's another way round of saying that
which is that if you have if this number
was comparable to the number of cubits
you would need to factor interestingly
large numbers that's bad news because if
you build a quantum computer that's
that's that big it will be taken away
from you because it will be it will have
all sorts of horrible military
applications that you will not be
allowed to play with however we can
build this many cubits and people who
you know live on the Beltway will not
get upset with us and we can still do
interesting chemistry of course this
isn't the whole story The the numbers of
gates as we've seen are alarmingly
large
so okay so a lot of repeating here but
we've seen this number number of times
before so we just take the born
Oppenheimer approximation treat the
nuclear as fixed and then the game is to
find the electronic energy as a function
of the nuclear coordinates and hey
Presto in second quantied form here's
our famous molecular electronic
hamiltonian again
so what I'm going to do in this talk is
take this hamiltonian and reduce it into
a hamiltonian for cubits in a number of
different
ways okay so what's the important
property so I defined this occupation
number basis but that cannot possibly be
the whole story because no no
information about symmetry of the wave
function is encoded in anything I've
said so far instead the information
about anti- symmetry gets encoded in The
Operators that Define the hamiltonian
through these fermionic computation
relations and just to Hammer the point
home this is the idea of a a good scheme
we have a number of ingredients so we
have a we can take a wave function of
electrons we can encode it into a wave
function of
cubits then we have an operator that
takes a state of cubits to a new state
of cubits hopefully there's a and then
there's a firic operator that takes a
state of the electrons to a new state of
the electrons and hopefully if we
inverse encode we get the same States
here so this is the definition of a
successful encoding scheme
okay so how do we how do we usually do
this or what's the what was the sort of
starting point for this work so it was
the uh idea that Jared has already
presented so we need to Define cubic
creation and Annihilation operators that
act on the occupation number basis but
which obey the same algebra as The
fironic Operators and the way you do
that is you attach these long strings of
Z operators so this little arrow here
just says I'm Cubit J everybody who has
index less than me gets acted on by a
zed z sorry um and so I have my C my
fermionic excuse me my Cubit operator
which is just the this operator here
that takes a zero and turns it into a
one that's Creation in the Cubit land
takes a one and makes it into a zero
that's annihilation in Cubit land and
then I have this string operator here
that if you plug these formula into the
anti computation relations you will find
that they these operators do indeed obey
the correct anti-commutation relations
therefore these are the Cub analoges of
The fermionic Operators so this is
originally from Jordan and vigner in
1928 the this use of it was proposed by
Rolando summer um in 2002 and in between
these years it was used very extensively
in condensed matap physics for um
transforming um backwards and forwards
between bionic and spin systems to
enable us to solve a whole bunch of
systems
exactly
okay so this is a play on words that
doesn't work at all in America where you
call this game Shoots and Ladders for
reasons that escape me but in England
it's called Snakes and Ladders um so we
have these long strings of Sigma Zs have
shown up in our hamiltonian in order to
get the anti- Symmetry properties right
okay so what we are going to end up
doing after we have trotterz and so on
and so forth is we're going to want to
exponentiate something that looks like
this the circuit to do this is simple
actually it's in neelson and Chang you
do a whole bunch of C Nots to
effectively compute the parity of this
set of cubits which is what this
operator depends upon you then do a
sigma Zed rotation and then you uncomp
compute the parity yeah I think there's
a paper Ti from about 12 years ago where
he reduces this linear change to log
Factor that's exactly what about
so so the
um so the uh so these l so these these
ladders of C Nots are exactly order n
long in Jordan vigner and so
unfortunately Maas I know you said order
n to the fourth makes you afraid this
should make you terrified because you
have get an extra factor of n so it goes
up to order n to the 5ifth or
login the login
has so the uh
okay so so as you said quite correctly
so uh this um problem was thought about
from a different point of view they
thought about how imagine I had a
fironic quantum computer so imagine my I
was Computing with fermionic orbitals um
what's the how many F fonic operations
do I have to do to do a single Cubit
gate operation and so bared in here is
exactly the mapping that we need to
improve this n the 5th to end the four
log n
um for pedagogical reasons this in that
paper they they think about the parity
basis so if you think about the
um what's happening in the Jordan vigner
transformation occupation is stored
locally which means that parity is a
non-local quantity you have to look at
many cubits to compute their parity and
so you end up with these long string
operators so in the parity basis why not
make parity the local quantity so you
store in the cubits the parity of a set
of orbitals so Cubit J and I store the
par the total parity of everyone with
index less than me then this is great we
can compute these parity quantities that
we're interested in just by looking at a
single
Cubit okay but now we still need a
raising a lowering operator and now
occupation is no longer a local quantity
because we're not storing occupation in
the
cubits so now instead of um having long
strings of Z's that compute parity we
have long strings of x's that
update um Cubit so if I flip if I want
to change one orbital occupancy I end up
changing all of the parities that
involve that orbital occupancy so I end
up instead of having long strings of Z's
on the left I end up with long strings
of x's on the right and these are again
order n long and I get no
advantage okay so both of these methods
both the occupation number and the
parity number bases end up with long
strings of py that scale like order n
and there's and they're equivalent so
what about some happy medium between
occupation number basis and parody basis
and this is exactly what we call the
bravit of
bases so what do they do so here's the
occupation number basis here's the bravi
of
basis so
um the uh what's indicated here by the
arrows is every time there's an arrow
this Cubit stores the sum of all of the
occupancies of the orbitals that have an
arrow pointing to it okay so we wrestled
with that paper for a while um to try
and find an economical explanation an
economical description of how this
transformation Works uh you know we drew
various pictures like this trying to
understand what what what was in bra's
mind um the simplest thing we came up
with was the following to to think about
the mapping in terms of the following
Matrix which is relatively easy to
construct um for any number of cubits so
this is a mapping not from states to
States but from Cubit labels to Cubit
labels so in my Cubit B in my occupation
number basis I have a bit string that
tells me the occupations and then over
here in my you K kit of basis I have a
bit string that tells me which logical
basis state that occupation number State
goes to so the way you construct this
Matrix is you start with a one so that's
easy to remember then you replicate that
block here and you fill in the bottom
row all right now I'm going to do it
again I'm going to take this block I'm
going to replicate it again and fill in
the bottom row now I do it again I
replicate that block here and I fill in
the bottom row What's Happening Here is
that one or one of the not things that's
noticeable is that the number of times
you end up with a sum that runs over all
of the cubits is getting increasingly
sparse you need fewer and fewer and
fewer of those as you add more and more
and more cubits so this is a you think
of number of orbitals this is a log n by
log n Matrix and you know okay it's not
unitary but that's okay because it
doesn't act on States it acts on Cub it
acts on labels of
States so that's the that's the bravi of
basis that's the new basis that you want
to use
okay so to Think Through um exactly how
this is going to work and how are we
going to take this transformation apply
it to the interacting firion hamiltonian
that we're interested in and understand
the the the uh spin Hamilton that come
out it's useful to define a whole bunch
of sets of cubits
so the uh first set is the update set of
uh U of J so if I take orbital J and I
change its
occupation which cubits do I have to act
on so that's the update set so I update
an orbital and then I have to update the
update set of
cubits okay so then there's also we're
interesting parity information because
we want to compute
phases so what set of
um cubits stores the total parity of all
orbitals with index less than J and
that's the parity set P of
J now of course cubits can only be Z one
so a any given Cubit can either store
the parity of excuse me it can either
store um the parity of orbital J or it
can be opposite to the parity of orbital
J and so then for reasons that are too
boring to talk about it's conf it's
convenient to Define this flip set F of
J which defines whether your Cubit is
telling you the parity or the opposite
parity and then the number of cubits in
these sets that this is not obvious but
it's true is at most log
n okay so how do we do it so for even
numbered orbitals the cubits store the
occupation directly so this is a fact
about the transformation it goes if you
go back to this Matrix you'll notice a
feature of it is that the every so often
there's a one on the diagonal that's
that corresponds to the even numbered
orbitals um and so for the
I just have the update set okay so if I
change the I'm I'm going to change the
occupation I'm applying a creation or
Annihilation operator I have to update
everything in the update set so I act
with X on everything in the update set I
have a
cubit um creation operator that just
changes that Cubit from 0 to one and
then on the parody set I apply the
phases but now none of these operators
are order n local they're order log n
local because they only act on sets of
cubits whose size is bounded above by
log n now there's a couple of different
sets so it's not strictly log n it's you
know at most to log n plus one um and
the same thing here so I just update
everything in the update set I act on it
I act I compute the phase from the
parity set and I apply the correct Cubit
operator okay so for odd-numbered
orbitals they don't store directly the
occupation of the uh the orbital so I
have to have
a cubit creation or Annihilation
operator that depends on whether the
flip set has even or odd parity okay so
if the flip set has even parity that
means that the Cubit stores the
occupation of the orbital if it has odd
parity that means it's the opposite and
so it just flips the definition of
creation and Annihilation and applies a
sign um so you just have this slightly
more
complicated uh Cubit operator but the
update and parity sets now because we
included the phase here which you know
is one of those things you do on the
Blackboard and then you end up
regretting when you write the paper we
end up having this R set which is the
the uh parity set minus the flip set
um so we get exactly the same structure
however we have a to update a bunch of
cubits because we've touched one and now
neither occupation nor parity is a local
observable um and we have to apply the
phase but we only have to act again on a
number of cubits which is bounded
logarithmically okay if you've never
seen a graph of the Hamming number there
it is I imagine at Microsoft research
you may have seen such a graph um so
these things are actually bounded above
by the Hamming um so for example this is
the parody set it's actually the Hamming
weight so if you are careful about
counting resources you should compute
the average Hamming weight weight and
that will tell you averaged overall
labelings that's um the the average
locality um but the punchline is that
you can simulate these things by order
log n poly Gates so when we so we know
that this transformation is
exponentially better than Jordan vigner
we replace an N by a log n so by that I
mean if you imagine having a fixed
capability inside your quantum computer
to bring groups of cubits together and
act on them with strings of poly
operators and so I get you the
experimentalist gives me some fixed
resource say that you can act on five
well if I use Jordan vigner that means I
can do five orbitals if I use this I can
do two to the five orbitals so therefore
it's
a a distinct Improvement so we know the
we know the um ASM totic scaling is
better but a good question is you know
this is a more complicated
transformation so um why is there a
crossover point where for small problems
it's better to use Jordan vigner and
then later on it's better to pay the pay
the extra cost of the complexity and use
this bravi kitv well so let's do the
simplest example which is H2 on a
minimal basis which has the virtue of
being the only one that's actually been
calculated on a quantum
computer modulo new new novel
techniques
um the only one that's been published
perhaps I should say um so okay so this
is the uh this is the the optical setup
from 2010 and these are the curves for
the minimal basis H2 so if we take this
transform if we take this
hamiltonian and just work out the
details here are the
hamiltonians um as you can see by
inspection these are
isospectral
um I'll just give you a minute to work
that out
um okay so something that's not so
obvious is what the computational cost
is
um
so from that ladder construction above
you know that if you have an n-fold
product tensor product of poly I say Z
here but it could be any string of py so
this requires 2 to the N minus one cots
and one single cubits gate oh yeah
excuse me so if I add a p if I flip one
of these to an X or is why I have to pay
two extra single Cubit Gates just to do
a local rotation to change to change my
local basis so if I ask about cost per
Trotter step now we haven't at all
solved any of the issues that that
suround Trotter we
haven't made you unafraid because it's
still enter the fourth log n um but the
cost for Trotter step is as follows so
it's good to collect together all the Z
things because obviously they commute so
you don't have to trotor eyesee them
separately so the single Cubit Z gates
are exactly the same here the single the
cots um for the Z part of the h
hamiltonian are worse for us because we
have a more complicated construction um
that significantly the off diagonal
terms in the hamiltonian those things
that one uh needs to worry about if
you're imagining using something like
the d-wave machine these are
significantly better for us well perhaps
significantly is a little overstating it
um the overall is that we actually per
Trot step we we suffer a little um it's
a little bit worse but overall
um depending how you trotor Rize you can
actually get a uh a slight
Advantage
so so just using this again 10-year-old
now paper by bravi and kitv um you can
replace order nend ladders of gates with
order log N Ladders so this is an
example
where you know an hour in the library
can save you a long time in the lab um
and so the Improvement increases with
more orbitals so it turns out actually
this is a terrible example because it's
so tightly constrained to electrons and
four orbitals that the actual advantage
of the method barely barely is barely
exhibited um
so this paper's out so it'll be I just
got the proofs today actually so it'll
be in Journal of chemical physics fairly
soon and it if you look at Nal 32 for
the Jordan vigner decomposition of this
thing you get this nasty string and then
for bravi kit it's very small so we have
um in addition to the paper we actually
have code um that implements all this so
we can take arbitrary sets of if you
tell us the integrals we can tell you
the hamiltonian
couplings and just remains to thank the
NSF and the Air Force and Howard Hughes
and this is our Quantum information in
Quantum computation Center which
hopefully will manage to continue for
another five years and thanks thank you
for your attention
so so Peter I'm going to make a claim
which that you can do better than that
but I think but maybe Bella can refute
that so so the story you're describing
um sounds similar to the study of peric
systems with tensor product States so as
you when tensor product states were
first proposed therefore spines systems
and then people thought well the natural
way to treat them for fion was to
introduce a drawn viant transformation
but then you'd have a long string of
operators and that seemed like a bad
thing and then um I think the Str
suggested you should use a bra KF
mapping uh but we didn't seem very
practical um and then we know now though
that if you set up uh the initial State
correctly to have a certain parity
constraints then um you can actually
absorb all these uh non-local signs into
a purely local operation and so what
that says if you can do the classic
computer what that means is that uh if
you have a if you prepare a qu state
with this with this parity structure and
you apply a physical hamiltonian uh then
for those then for those types of
simulations there is no need for a
nonlocal string would you agree agree
with that right so so you don't you
don't yeah so actually you can bypass
this problem um I think fundamentally
the description for that is actually in
the same paper by by by
and it's just very hard to from that
we're currently thinking about whether
the tricks used in t netork States can
be extended to this yeah that just means
you toop the log fact the end to the for
oh yes yes I know no but just for the
for the mapping of the but how much of
the hbert space do you sacrifice by
these parody construction nothing
nothing well I thought you said I
thought you said you compute only need
more cubits you need to I mean your H
yeah but you're not
sacrificing you can safely diagonalize
in a par sector as long as you're H as
long as you're interested in involving
with hamiltonians which are parity
conserving ESS all reason
reasonable oh so that you're not using
the c space sparsely to encode the uh
States no you the sense because you need
more Cubit than before the constant
Factor more more probably
Conant
small at most to you need some CU and
keep might need to on a general graph I
think it might be
more
it's po no
cubits well you need to see two degree
of Freedom if if you B it as a director
but now you have where nonlocal hopping
to for
example so
polom I mean that sounds rather
significant so if you have if normally
originally you were taking M cubits to
encode your state and you had the ENT
the fourth log in and now you're saying
you might need polinomial and then
cubits to encode the information to get
rid of the log I need more cubits to get
rid of the
log but I think I also get
more gate operation have to
do so you so you pay with more cubits
and more gate operations yes you get rid
of the L yes I I don't understand
that but got it I mean if you if you
take a if you en do a first fonti
encoding of this then what you say is
true right you have a um you have a
hamiltonian that preserves the symmetry
of the wave function and therefore if
you initialize in an anti symetry State
then it will simply be preserved and you
don't have to do any of
this but I think that's not I I
understand that's not what you're saying
yeah yeah yeah
but
yeah well the the the realization in Den
Network States is that if you like this
is pretty obvious if you have like a
unitary circuit on top of some state
that you can kind of locally preserve
this par
preserve and then that that makes all
the non strings
disappear I don't think it's quite clear
to me yet what this means in
practice
kind well the
original thing and this was also work a
different
language is that put a some on every
yeah um every Bond so that will make you
need at least Factor more cbids I'm not
sure but that's every Bond where you can
hop but now if you have longer hoppings
yeah so for local for local honi it's
certainly yeah for local ones it is good
like mod that helps oh I see
long because in that in thatti Sak paper
they get down to a constant locality
right because they're on a square gri
yes so for local be constant and if you
density interactions
also for something non local you have
done
yeah okay
yeah so it'll be it'll be a constant in
the number of
like Conant number of IND
IND
we have still more are there any more
questions or comments Peter do you so so
one thing I don't like about the um
Jordan v transformation is that
generally I have no capability of
parallelization that basically there's
ladders create blocks which prevent me
from squishing things so when I switch
to this
brati do you have a sense of like what
the rate of collisions is I mean it's
got to be good right it's a three
structure so it's
that's bad I think say bad yeah yeah I
don't think there's
any there's any great
yeah we thought about's
only I guess
tree more
CS another question we don't know is
this is an N orbital to n Cubit
construction so if you can go from n
orbitals to more than n cubits whether
you can can help yeah I mean exactly
like the do most terms in
parall
after
great great let's thank Peter
again
yes yep
great oh I'm forgetting to introduce
you okay so now we have Ken Brown from
Georgia Tech and he's going to talk to
us about error correction and
architectures for quantum chemistry on a
quantum computer thanks Christa uh
anyway thanks for having me out it's
nice to see everybody a lot of most I
know half of you at least to start it's
also nice to be back in Washington which
is where I'm from
originally um so my my interest in
Quantum Computing is mostly about how to
actually build these things which I
think in the end leads to error
correction so my
lab um we actually
do basically three things so first we
try to build ion trap quantum
computers uh it's hard so we do a lot of
theory thinking about how to make it
easier through error correction and
maybe Quantum
control and then I also like to think
about in the process of building this
device I'm making very complicated very
sensitive Quantum systems and can I use
that sensitivity to do other things and
so for instance we can uh do single
molecular ion mass spectrometry in a way
which is non-destructive for instance um
we work with you know Sabra for this qu
FR quantum computer I of course also
work for these irpa guys who are mostly
interested in Breaking codes and um we
work on building these devices and then
we work on thinking about some of these
architecture questions which is what I'm
going to talk about today
so uh these few slides of background I
feel like I should just skip but just so
we're all together I guess so the way I
think about at a classical computer you
need an exponential number of electrons
to represent n electrons and it's kind
of anology but with a molecule you can
use n electrons to represent n
electrons um so as we all know fan
realized that well if I had one Quantum
system to represent another quantum
system maybe we could get over that
scaling barrier and I disagree a little
bit with Michael when he was mentioning
how physicists could think of new
algorithms because I think the problem
with physicists is they think this and
then there's like no there's no tool and
so as we
know Peter Shore is a mathematician able
to actually
solve um and lay out how to solve a
specific mathematical
problem really what is what really got
us going and what's amazing is that sub
routine of the phase estimation
algorithm is the basis of the way we
think about doing all these other
methods um so as a reminder just to
compare these things we've already
talked you know quite a bit about how
the phase estimation algorithm works so
for factoring
there
are basically three great things first
the state that you start with here it's
very easy to prepare it's just one
second that there's a way to to um put
this unitary basically 2 to the N times
in a way which is logarithmic and M and
then finally when we get to the
measurement we can do this continued
fraction expansion to get out the factor
when we look at the the ways that we
talk about doing these Ground St
estimation algorithms first suggested by
Seth
Lloyd first it's hard to say whether or
not we have the ground state and you
know Jared showed like the worst case
scenario that if we get a larger and
larger system it becomes smaller and
smaller the second thing which I think
is uh matias's main point and actually
my main concern as well is that I don't
know how to do this any faster than just
doing it two to the end times and I
think that cost is like the real if we
could solve that I would feel a lot more
comfortable um and finally you know the
output depends on this input somehow I'm
I'm optimistic about
that all right so what I want to talk
about is how the cost is even worse than
Mattia said due to architectural
constraints and constraints involving
error
correction okay so we know in principle
I to be optimistic all right
we yeah I like to talk in an optimistic
way and say pessimistic
things so we know from you know this
paper by Peter and Alain um that
basically if we could get very good
cubits we forget about the time cost we
could start to solve you know these
these these difficult to solve exact
spectr physical chemical
problems all right so what's nice is the
quantum computer in some sense solves
the problem because it ows us to use K
electrons to represent n
electrons but now we have to get down to
things like time and what's this value
of
K all right
so the way I think about it is you know
classical computer we map bit strings to
bit strings we can stop at any time
measure the computer doesn't change the
state of the computer quantum computers
we operate we map bit strings to superp
positions of bit strings and when we do
a measurement we change the state of the
computer and the most important thing
about that is that it leads uh kind of
directly to this no cloning result so in
a classical computer we can always take
the bit string in the classical computer
and copy
it um now in Quantum Computing we can do
that in one basis but it we can't do it
in the arbitrary basis because it
prevents linearity or uh violates
linearity and that has I think two
important things one is for error
correction and the other is for
architectures so on the error correction
side we know classically we can always
think about some kind of redundancy code
and if our error rate is small we just
take a majority vote and then based on
that majority vote uh you know correct
so I mean I think in some sense That's
the basis of democracy we assume that we
take a majority vote of enough people it
won't be so bad um in a quantum computer
computer you can't stop and measure it
because you want to maintain this
coherence so instead of measuring the
bit string and taking a majority vote we
measure an operator which tells us what
Subspace we're in so if there's a single
error say from this first bit flips it
takes us from the blue Subspace to the
green Subspace we just ask what Subspace
we're in we're in the green
Subspace we flip it back to the blue
Subspace and we're able to keep the
coherence between our encoded Quantum
bits so what is the cost of measuring
the
subspaces
so um a common code very common
concatenated code is the steam code
which encodes one logical Cubit into
seven physical
cubits and it requires measuring
basically um six different subspaces and
each of each of those subspaces will be
measured using four quantum auxiliary
Quantum bits which basically service the
way to dump the entropy they allow us to
measure which Subspace we're in and then
we fix it so if we
um if we want to minimize the number of
cubits we only need four more cubits to
do this Subspace measurement on top of
the extra six we need for
encoding but
typically because the quantum comp
computer is not going to be you know we
need to make sure we get everything done
before it falls apart to minimize time
it makes sense to sort of parallelize
the way we we measure these blocks so we
kind of measure all the the subblocks at
the same
time now on top of that um and this goes
back to what Christa was talking about
earlier is for most Quantum Computing
codes the Clifford group corresponding
to these poly Gates the hadamard and the
C not can be done in a way which is
transversal
which means I just take my encoded Cubit
and I apply hadamard to all the cubits
that make up the smaller pieces but the
non- Clifford group Gates um you can
pick any one you want usually people
pick this T gate or pi over8 and I'm
sorry they didn't call it pi over four
personally but it's stuck you need to
prepare this state and then actually
teleport it in and
um the the one thing which I think is
funny about this post- selection
business that we talked about earlier is
that almost all error correcting
protocols that are done in a fault
tolerant way rely on post selection
because I need to prepare this state in
a way which is um I need to prepare this
state with some underlying Fidelity and
I do that by teleporting it in and
looking at these
measurements fixing it if I can but
often times rejecting it because it's
the wrong state it doesn't do anything
to the computation it's just like a
resource that I need to build up in
order to get through the
computation all right yeah so so uh in
terms of building a quantum
computer the when you think about fault
tolerant Quantum a correction the sort
of um nightmare is that in a physical
level single Cubit operations are
usually easy two Cubit operations are
hard but in a fault tolerant setting
single cubid operations are hard they're
actually much harder
all
right okay so now given those
constraints what we want to do is figure
out how to create this
operator a u of 2 to the
m so uh you know Peter just talked about
the bravic method I just use as my
example this Jordan vigner
transformation uh again we're just going
to build everything with a Trotter
formula and the tough part
and I'm I'm really unhappy to hear about
this tree like nature so if I look at
the
uh um Jordan vigner transformation this
is that ladder of spins and it does two
things so the first thing it does is it
prevents me from being able to do these
things in parallel it forces me to
basically apply them one at a time so
the end of the four actually becomes
part of the time the second thing is
you'll notice that it reaches over this
whole
Space um and that's kind of an
issue
because it could be that the cubits that
you want to connect physically are
actually very far away from each
other and uh because of the no cloning
theorem I can't necessarily put the
state onto like a wire and fan it out
all over the place uh I actually have to
move the bit to the bit it needs to
interact with
all right so our way to move things
quickly is this teleportation scheme so
teleportation uses these entangled
pairs um to and these two measurements
to map a wave function from this Cubit
to this Cubit now the beautiful thing
about it is the speed in which that
happens assuming that you have the epr
pairs floating around all over the
system is just the speed of classical
measurement and
communication so relative to the
everything else that's going on in your
quantum computer that's very fast so we
can move things around quickly but we
still have to move it from point to
point to
point so um an idea of how to think
about building like an architecture here
is you have a block which contains all
of the resources you need to compute so
they'll have the logical Cubit all the
illa you need for error correction all
the an need for TG preparation and then
some channels by which you use these um
entangled pairs to move information
around and this is a particular
architecture called QA from Fred Chong's
group at Santa
Barbara presented at ISA in
2006 so since that 2006 paper and some
earlier work uh both Fred Chong at Santa
Barb and John kuato at at Berkeley they
thought about all kinds of different
ways to like re you know
configure the system to minimize space
or time depending if the cubits have
different jobs or not um but then of
course we want to try to implement this
so we want to implement it on a real
physical system and my interest is nion
traps so one
um yeah sorry I have lost said movie so
my my basic idea is there's an idea of
kind of a charge couped device ion trap
um first suggested by kinsky mon Rowan
weinland weinland won the Nobel Prize
this year he's also the nicest guy on
the planet uh he so so the idea is the
ions will be stored in all of these um
surface electrode arrays of of traps
they'll move around they'll go through
this dance of er correction kind of
continually so what we can do is we can
say well let's be optimistic and assume
that we can make these ions um
very good have like a very low failure
rate the physical gate speed is kind of
slow 10
micros decoherence time has been
measured to be quite long and and is
longer even since these original values
um but these are the values used in this
uh isap paper for
factoring and the cost of concatenated
era correction there's the good and the
bad so the good is you see that as I go
up in levels of error correction the
failure rate drops off dramatically it
actually drops off double
exponentially the bad is the gate time
increases
exponentially and the number of cubits
and sort of gates also increases
exponentially so I get this double
exponential
win so it's efficient um but this
slowing in time and increasing of
circuit size is kind of a
problem so
now um the way so I'm in a second I'm
going to show you a graph with too much
information on it so to get us set for
that graph here's one with just a
triangle uh what I'm going to do is I'm
going to think about these
computational any computation in terms
of the number of logical computational
steps so there might be many par there
might be many parallel Gates happening
in that one time step but I'm just
interested in sort of clock Cycles if
you will and then the number of logical
cubits and then because I'm interested
in error correction what I want to say
is the probability of any gate
failing on any Cubit is less than this
product right so my circuit size
basically so you know I check if I don't
do any error correction it gives me a
line which gives me a space of
algorithms that I can complete without
failing if I go to level one you know
the line moves It's a larger space and I
can imagine just moving this line up and
until the triangle which represents the
algorithm I want to complete is beneath
this line and I can get the answer with
some
probability that's the
plan
okay
now at this point I can draw a line here
which is the total number of logical
cubits um required to to to to this
algorithm all right so now here's the
too much information we'll try to go
through it really slowly
so uh in set's and Fred jong's Isa paper
what they're interested was factoring so
this block here is the number of logical
cubits and computational time required
to factor a 1024-bit
number now
imagine um so actually so kind of the
opposite of Peter's thing about the
spies taking you away what I like to
think about is in terms of vacuum tube
computer right the spies built them
during World War II and then afterwards
you know gave them to scientists to do
what they wish uh so imagine the spies
have secretly built this 1024 cubic
computer and then they come and they
give it to you and they say hey we built
this thing we've cracked all the codes
you can now use it uh what could you do
with it in terms of a Quantum
simulation so we picked something we
know the answer to which is the
transverse ising model and we looked at
it for a series of Cubit size n50 100 to
150 and we
calculated um both the number of cubits
required in the computational time steps
now the first
thing this going this direction what we
have is that the N is
increasing and for n it is incredibly
efficient what is not efficient for is
the Precision of which I want to know
the energy right it's the same that I
basically have to wait a long time to
get a good energy now on top of that
um this these diagonal
lines correspond to these levels of
error
correction
so this diagonal line here is the level
two error
correction this is level one this is
level three so this block here is all
level three
and that is kind of to me that is the
extra level of nightmare so here at
level two we have an operation time
which is a quarter of a
second for factoring you still win
because you can Factor this 10 24bit
number in 11 days and everything is
great but if you look down here you see
that we can
calculate to a Precision of you know
somewhere between five and 10 bits
um the transfer sizing model which is
not so promising and when we get to a
higher Precision number out here um we
end up in level three in which the clock
speed slows down to basically one
operation per 10 seconds yeah let me
just make sure I understand the scale so
on the Y AIS is logical cuit that's
right logical cuit and uh in order to
calculate the step function where you go
to levels of concatenation in the scheme
code yeah you're inputting Fidel these
that come from ion trap that's right
what what numbers you using so so we're
using uh these numbers here so we're
assuming really good gate failure rates
10 Theus
7 uh so the Fidelity is 1 - 10 seven
that's right and is that assumption used
for both one and two Cubit Gates uh
that's right that's right that's right
which what are the current numbers in
TRS for those two types of CAS so for
one Cub Gates it's 10us 6 now I believe
two cubic Gates is 10us 3 I see so
there's a big and also um so there so
that that's a big gap right now I would
say in in real ion trap quantum
computers our real challenge right now
is better to cubic
Gates okay and uh what would that do if
you couldn't get to 10- 7 2 Cub GES how
would that affect the that step function
uh if you could get to the 10
yeah so the problem is
um right so the error
out is
uh right well that's an S of ASM totic
this right so but but but guess I'm just
wondering how many Slayers of
contamination would you need well so
that's the problem so from Christa's
earlier work we know that the threshold
when you have a logical architecture is
not as good as you think so this number
is probably about 10 Theus
6 for the steam code so at the end I'm
going to talk about surface codes so
honestly I think we got to move to
surface codes okay so Ste code is really
not the right
yeah so so so for the steam code because
we're below threshold we gain right
something right but but but if we but if
we
uh but I guess I want to emphasize about
this even ASM totic scaling is that this
is a great win if you're far from
threshold but if you're right at the
limit it's you know it's you win but
it's not it's bad so what would happen
is these would basically
they would fall off faster basically
right the the area that you could do
level one level two would all of this
would shift to the
left um now what I want to point out is
that my optimism comes from the fact
that Shores
algorithm uh there's just been a ton of
work so if you implement it in a kind of
naive simplest method with smallest
number of cubits it takes
forever but if you throw in in more
cubits basically to increase the
parallelism you can shift right from
something you can't do at level four to
something you can do at level two and I
think that area of quantum chemistry
calculations there's still a lot of
space
there all right so uh this is just okay
so we didn't do this night like uh
sometimes people think well how could it
be so bad for the iing model
and so I want to point out that we
didn't do this in a naive way so first
it turns out that we can you can do
something like a fan out through
preparing cat
States because the ising model pretty
much completely commutes you can do
everything in parallel so there's not
this end of the four scaling right so we
have already bad times no end of the
four scaling we have order one
scaling uh the other thing is there's a
lot of room into how do you make an
arbitrary rotation from a finite set of
rotations so Quantum error correction
forces you to have a finite set of
rotations and that leads into those
large
numbers and so our the way we ended up
calculating that was we assumed that the
Trotter error had to be less than the
bits of phase precision and the Silva TI
error had to be less than the Trotter
error and that's from that we just
calculated everything um in terms of the
architecture what was interesting was
there is sort of a natural setup in
which most of the architecture is a
block which is preparing these T States
all the time because we're constantly
doing these rotations we want to be
ready so half of the whole architecture
is just preparing these states so we can
do the rotations on
demand
um quarter are these ancillas which are
used to make this cat state to do this
fan out and try to solve our
communication problem and then finally
the last quarter is the the quantum bits
that are the
circuit um so an idea of the overhead so
let me ask yeah how uh what extent are
things driven by the time required to do
the K solve
algorithm because almost completely
because there's a you know an inherent
inefficiency there of U it's a
polinomial problem
it's log one Epsilon versus log Epsilon
squ another you asked the theoretical
density
yeah the right answer is sort of there
at half the uh or square root of one
right right but just hard to find it
that's right that's right so if you had
a better algorithm for that that would
be very together that' be huge so as an
example you guys have this nice
algorithm for uh for basically not
increasing the number of cubits at all
but relative to running the normal
solvic algorithm that everybody uses
it's like at least three orders of
magnitude better it's yeah so this um
yeah this paper with Christa and bov uh
it's great so it shifts all of these
numbers this direction and then if we
look at
um this this Cody Jones
paper uh it reduced the time even more
but at the cost of um a huge increase in
cubits and this I'm being a little bit
generous to them um I haven't yet gone
through Ying gu's paper unlike where
that we have a a new Vector that's
somewhere um it'll uh decreases the
computational time by better than Cody
Jones and fewer CU than Cody Jones oh
great great between blue and red yeah so
so this one is pretty interesting
because in this particular example um
this one stays
it it it helps quite a bit but we're
still in this level three era correction
which we don't really want to be at this
one actually takes us to a point we
can't
do um but if I shift down in my
Precision required to just 20 bits then
it's you know they both work and there's
some argument about whether time is more
valuable to you or cubits are more
valuable to you and that's actually
quite nice so I think in the context of
a whole algorithm
it might be that the type of
decomposition you use will depend on
that algorithm and kind of where you
are relative to the space for erir
correction in your architecture like
where your cubits our our paper um you
need a lot of additional resource States
that's right that's right so if you have
that ability to place them in your
architecture like you lean out this one
that might be a good way to go yeah that
yes yes I agree and I so and I think
there there there should be some similar
method for solving this end to the four
problem right that if we can
somehow spend in cubits maybe doubling
the space to take care of the parody and
whatever to shrink everything down is I
think a good
direction all right so just in terms of
uh a little bit of update on ION trap
stuff one thing that we've been thinking
about is actually having instead of a
huge chip with all of these ions
to have smaller chips and then a few of
these ions Photon coupled where again we
use basically post selection to try to
generate epr pairs most of the time it
fails but when it succeeds we know it
succeeds right we no false positives and
what's great is that kind of
architecture has a really natural
um a really natural mapping onto this
same idea of a Quantum logic array it's
just now these epr channels aren't
actually channels in the computer
they're channels that happen through
this Photon interconnect
switch all right so finally
um going too fast
so I wanted to just talk about surface
codes just a tiny bit um so actually so
my so when I was a gr student Michael
came and talked at the misery Institute
up at Berkeley whatever and uh the and
you were wearing this Fringe leather
jacket so unfortunately I think I only
seen you one time since then and I
always think of you in this Fringe
leather jacket like that's my my
vision I think that was the last time
for that
jacket uh but you were talking about
topological quad Computing and you had
all these pants like coming together and
at the time I was like I just seemed it
seemed too far out to me uh the one
dimensional fringes were a Special Touch
that's right you that that vest is uh
Berkeley
par perfect so so this paper by Rosen
rosendorf and Harrington in the
follow-up paper by rido Harrington and
Goyle where they show that you don't
really need a topological computer but
if you just take that idea and use it to
make a code and they show how to make
that code Cod um the thresholds become
around
1% now what happened is I think
experimentalists initially were hesitant
about this because um like all good
error correcting code people when they
show the overhead cost they show the
overhead cost right at
threshold and the cost right at
threshold is
ridiculous um but if you could get down
to these 10 Theus 3 or even like 10us 5
or 6
then the overhead cost relative to
concatenated codes I believe is better
and I will um not show that now but I'm
I'm if you actually look at an algorithm
of any scale it
wins uh so the basic idea is there going
to be a surface code we can think of it
as a surface abstractly it's going to
have different kinds of defects which we
can think of as Primal and dual we can
think about the um error correcting
or sorry we can think about the quantum
circuit for the Clifford Gates is being
braidings of these defects in
time um you can think about this all
being in space but it's basically your
computer lives at this point in time and
you shift these defects around each
other uh in the same way you can you
have the same problem as always which is
you have to bring in these non- Clifford
Gates somehow and we do that by
generating a patch using that patch to
then generate these magic States doing
uh teleportation like
usual
and
um yeah so the the I think the surface
code people are really enamored by
making these giant braids they're like
yeah we can twist all this stuff
together get this huge ball of spaghetti
but what I like is you can actually make
a really natural mapping onto the
architectures we already know and the
way you do that is you take two of these
Primal holes to Ser as your Cubit and
you assume they don't move anywhere you
you force them to be fixed in some
location now in this in this area they
may wrap around each other to do single
Cubit
Gates but then from this previous slide
which this is just a teleportation
scheme I can use the Dual defects as
these air channels floating around now
I'm sure this is not the optimal way to
like minimize space for surface code but
in terms of like trying to calculate
resources and actually building a device
where pretty much all the devic is just
doing the same thing all the time
controllers are easier uh seems pretty
promising to me um and and and pretty
nice now the the thing which is missing
here is this ancillary block is going to
be the block I need to generate these
magic States in order to do these non
Clifford Gates and so there'll be some
like extra huge chunk here probably
around each Cubit to to take care of
that so
um just in conclusion so from my
perspective I think the no cloning
theorem leads to a pretty big overhead
for quantum computers um both in terms
of quantum correction which people have
thought a lot about but also in terms of
communication because I have to somehow
I have to carry the information with me
wherever I
go uh what's nice is we can solve that
in some um
to some degree through teleportation and
that these uh entangled pairs
effectively at the cost of you know
preparing them beforehand creates a
computer where everything is completely
connected um topological codes without
too much work can be mapped to current
architecture ideas
um but then this again kind of points to
Jared's thing about you know I'm
building a totally Universal
you know so far I've only thought about
pretty much totally Universal ideas can
I build some either topological code
specific architecture or even canade
code architecture which is built to be
optimal for these quantum chemistry
problems can I like what is what is the
what is the right underlying
architecture for Jordan
vigner uh bra kayv um
Etc and that's that and so that I'll
just this is my group of uh
we yeah so we so in addition to the
quantum Computing stuff again we work on
these cold molecular ions you can find
out more about us here um that's all
thanks yeah why to we TI okay so we had
a lot of group pictures where everybody
is like standing on you know standing on
a
staircase uh Graham would always wear
this Faulty
Towers don't mention the war shirt uh
and JB was like I am sick and tired of
these photos and he's like next photo I
just want everybody to wear ties and
we're like okay so that's it that's but
normally nobody wears
T yeah are you g to do an addition to
that slide the too busy slide with where
your surface code implementation that
architecture would come out yeah I I
need to do that I haven't done that yet
so what's so one thing which is nice um
and it's very similar to actually guom
and Christ paper where they talk about
when you do solvic aive in this other
way there's no longer steps it's smooth
and so what's nice about the
concatenated code is it's also
smooth more or less surface codes yeah
sorry surface codes more or less smooth
there's a little bit of steps due to the
distillation is still concatenated but
but yeah I would like to remake this
plot
um yeah so what are the technological
difficulties with iron trft
model
um so right now sort of what's the so so
so so our our
um so we have two problems so one is
we're trying to make sure we can scale
up and
uh I would say that our yeah the
reducing size of elements uh it means
connect like showing that we can build
elements that we can then put together
without any extra complication right um
so that's one problem and I think we're
I think we're making good progress there
but our key challenge has been the best
Gates people do um involve these lasers
and so then you got to think about laser
delivery to the whole trap and there's
been some recent work by Dave wiland
group looking at actually switching to
just microwave Gates and so you actually
um you fabricate these electrodes that
have a little bit of magnetic field and
previously people weren't sure if you
could do two cubic Gates because the way
the two cubic gates work is the ions
repel each other and so they have some
shared motion you send in a photon which
knocks this ion gets the other ion to
move stop it by sending in a photon on
this ion and so the microwave um
basically Al because the wavelength is
too long can't really create that Force
but it can if you add in a little bit of
magnetic field gradient and so people
are pushing that way and hopefully those
will lead to really good two cubic
Gates um what is nice about iron traps
is again one cubit gates are really
great right now um measurement is also
also really it's this fluoresence
detection it's very easy um I think it's
the the record there now is 59 of
measurement
so I think it's yeah scalability to
Gates a couple years ago I was hearing
about problems with uh heating of
anomalous uh sources yeah attempting to
scale down to ions on a chip sort of
model yeah
so fundamentally you would assume that
that for perfect devices the heating
should go like um one over the distance
squared but in practice it goes like one
over distance to the 4th
um people have been able to suppress it
by using cryogenically cooled traps
which is a bit of a bummer because
before I thought one of our big
advantages was we didn't have to cool
everything uh but one thing they've
shown recently is basically iron trap uh
quantum computer people are bad surface
scientist and it turns out that
basically we'd spend all this time
fabricating these traps in clean rooms
and we would like take it in air we just
walk it over to the Trap and put it in
and on the way it basically picks up a
lot of carbon and so um pop Dave papus
at Boulder has shown that if you come in
and you clean off that
carbon the anomalous heating goes
away the downside is even at 10 the
minus 10 tour that carbon will come back
so you need to think about um so so you
have plenty of time to do a computation
on it because that still will take a few
days for it to come back but but but
it's not um it's not permanently
solved probably you could solve it
permanently if you did the cleaning plus
the cold and then it would never migrate
back but I'm very yeah I'm very uh
bullish on iron traps I'm also very
bullish on superconductors those are my
two favorites yeah so the key thing is
was a on but can you cover it with
something wrong rather than trying to
keep it clean can you cover you just get
the dirt would still get on top of it
right that's the it would go on top of
the cover on top of the cover yeah
because it's just it's not it's very
very little dirt but it's just a few
carbon atoms covering this more or less
smooth metal surface and that creates a
little bit of
voltage fluctuations which leads to the
heating what mean is like if you covered
it with like a very perfect material
like graphine or something would that
protect it yeah so people thought about
graphine because they think maybe things
will stick less well to graphine than
they stick to
Metals um the only graphine trap that's
been tested so
far uh they somehow in the process just
got a big piece of dust on it and so
it's it's like you can literally you can
see in the laser scattered this big
piece of dust and of course the heating
rate was terrible so yeah people people
are thinking about it but in some sense
you know stuff will still stick and your
graphing would have to be really
perfect so how how close to move from
10us 3 2 cubic G and IR trap to 104 105
how like how plausible or how quickly do
you think that could so I think it
depends on on this continued
um fabrication of these magnetic
gradients with
microwaves
um if th that continues to work well
it's nice the problem with the way we
normally do it with the lasers is you do
this Ramon transition and there's always
some spontaneous submission so in
principle if you had infinite laser
power you could solve it and uh this
paper
by uh yeah anyway this 2005 paper by
ozeri this number isn't a real number
but it's a it's it's comes from oar's
like what is the physical limit of
this um but unfortunately this it just
seems like there's too much laser power
but what's nice about 10us
4 uh is for surface codes you start to
get low low enough below threshold that
it could
work yeah you're right on I guess right
on the edge right right right well
depending what distance code you're
using but it seems you know with the 10
and Aus 4 if you're using a you know
distance three surface code um you know
you're right on the edge of getting some
correction properties for
memory and right right so it be I'm just
thinking you know for near-term
experimental demonstration of a surface
code I TRS are pretty close um that's
right just a little bit further that' be
the downside the the downside of the
surface code the other reason why I
think people were kind of reluctant
about it is the cost of one gate on a
Surface code is a lot the cost of many
gates is not the cost of many gates is
not so bad right and that's that's
scaling it's hard to do the first
experiment but well my other question is
if you guys have studied what how the
threshold changes you know we always
study the threshold for the surface code
for a memory yeah so so this gate
operation do you think threshold is
going to change uh so so the gate like
to so Tate threshold is um I think 7% is
the latest value which isn't bad which
good
yeah any other
questions okay let's think can oh let's
have Peter asked question go back
to that's really the only problem that
seems because one of the things that's
happened in the last five years is now
all these systems have become triogen so
you don't have a 10 infrastructure to go
oh yeah no it's it's way nicer the
there's some
um yes I mean we have a centic system we
have we just have these like terrible
problems of like the pump vibrates trap
vibrates so now if we lock to the pump
everything is stable but if we just
tried to run without locking to the pump
it's like it looks like there are two
ions there's only one
ion uh no no but but the weird thing is
um
I guess I can say this because I'm just
making fun of my own work but when we
first did a cryogenic ion trap we got a
huge gain in the heating rate huge gain
like forers of magnitude but it's partly
because the way we were fabricating them
was not that clean now that we fabricate
them more
cleanly when we use the cryogenic Trap
we get you know much more modus game and
so it seems like to do the next that we
need this next level of cleaning first
followed by
cross let's thank Ken
again